bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regardant
direct un grand témoin historien ce soir
Jean garrigue bonsoir spécialiste de
l'histoire politique vous publiez chez
thaïlandi et l'Élysée contre Matignon le
couple infernal de la 5ème République on
va en parler on est ensemble pendant une
heure pour décrypter l'actualité de ce
jeudi 12 janvier d'actualité ce soir se
joue dans l'hémicycle en ce moment même
les députés des pâtes du port de
l'uniforme à l'école dans le cadre de la
niche du rassemblement national Brigitte
Macron figurez-vous et favorable ça
n'est pas passé inaperçu à leur bonne ou
mauvaise idée pour gommer les marqueurs
sociaux faire respecter la laïcité dans
les collèges lycées on en débat dans un
instant avec nos invités puis aux
alentours de 20h15 les partis prises de
nos affranchis et puis le bourbon
Express nouveau rendez-vous avec Elsa
montanava l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée vous êtes prêts je suis prêt
Jean garrigue c'est vert ça vous regarde
c'est parti on y va
[Musique]
tous en uniforme figurez-vous que le
débat est oui fait son chemin à
l'Assemblée si tous les élèves étaient
habillés pareil certains députés y
compris dans la majorité ivoire la
solution au problème de l'école laïcité
longueur de la jupe voile disparité
sociale mais tyrannie des marques
bonsoir Andrea cottara merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes le porte-parole du
rassemblement national le RN je le
disais discute en ce moment même dans
l'hémicycle de cette proposition de loi
qui dont il est à l'initiative qui vise
à rendre obligatoire le port d'une tenue
uniforme c'est le terme dans le texte
dans les établissements publics Sylvain
Maillard député de renaissance va nous
rejoindre dans un tout petit instant il
a quelques votes à garantir
manifestement dans l'hémicycle et lui
fait partie d'un groupe de réflexion sur
le même sujet bonsoir Carole aux herbib
et merci d'être là vous êtes proviseur
adjointe du lycée Voltaire à Paris et
puis membre de l'exécutif du syndicat
national des personnels de direction de
l'éducation les chefs d'établissement
entre autres et puis bonsoir Yannis
roder ravi de vous retrouver visage
familier de cette émission vous êtes
professeur d'histoire-géographie en
Seine-Saint-Denis et membre du conseil
des sages de la laïcité c'est
intéressant parce que pas mal de
signalements sont en lien avec avec le
sujet dont on va parler ce soir
évidemment Jean garrigue on a besoin de
regarder l'historien c'est un vieux
débat c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
vous intervenez quand vous voulez mais
je vais d'abord donner la parole à mon
camarade Stéphane blackovski pour son
billet pour nous planter le décor il a
200 secondes pour nous expliquer
pourquoi justement ce débat revient au
Palais Bourbon le chrono de Blacko tout
de suite
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir vous m'avez vu
remettre mon micro dans la poche non je
ne crois pas vous ne l'avez pas vu non
mais là vous vous insistez je vais finir
par le voir c'est à vous alors on a
perdu quelques secondes mais si j'ai
bien compris le débat ce soir c'est sur
le retour de l'uniforme à l'école moi
j'ai 55 ans donc pour être honnête c'est
quand même pas la première fois que je
vois surgir ce débat dans l'actualité
bon par exemple en 2017 je vous rappelle
que c'était une proposition du candidat
Fillon la présidentielle et à l'époque
l'idée ironisait un peu en disant c'est
franchement pas nouveau cette histoire
d'uniforme donc si ça sentait déjà un
peu le réchauffé en 2017 cette histoire
qu'est-ce qu'on va dire en 2022
franchement moi je trouve que le
meilleur truc c'est le coup du serpent
de mer c'est un serpent de merdé à te
dire regarde on a fait un photo du
phénomène c'est un truc qui surgit de
temps en temps on s'excite ça redescend
dans les profondeurs et ça revient donc
on peut le voir avancer 2004 Xavier
darkos et le premier à lancer l'idée
2009 Sarkozy reprend cette histoire dans
son plan banlieue 2015 alors ça c'est la
première proposition de loi c'est l'UMP
qui fait cette proposition de loi 2017
je l'ai dit c'est François Fillon qui
fait ressortir 2018 nouvelle proposition
de là c'est plus le MP ça a changé c'est
devenu les LR entre temps 2020 cette
fois-ci c'est quelques députés isolés de
la majorité qui tentent le coup et puis
on arrive en 2022 voilà où c'est le RN
qui fait ressortir ce bon vieux serpent
de mer alors quel est le but du RN moi
je vous dirais que globalement c'est de
pas comme toujours chercher là
respectabilité donc ils enfourchent ce
bon vieux cheval de bataille de la
droite en disant voyez ils disent à
droite nous on dit pareil on pourrait
s'entendre d'ailleurs ce matin il y
avait Jean-Philippe Tanguy qui était sur
Inter et on peut pas dire qu'il était
très très remonté pour faire respecter
coûte que coûte la laïcité on l'écoute
les signes distinctifs de religieux par
exemple si vous avez un uniforme qui est
correctement appliqué par définition ne
peuvent pas exister donc je ne vois pas
comment il pourrait y avoir une
exception à ça
d'avoir une petite croix un petit signe
religion une petite main de fatma ça n'a
jamais été un signe croisé
même une petite main de fatma tant que
c'est sur le uniforme ça les dérange pas
plus que ça donc c'est cette entreprise
de respectabilité donc en fait ceux qui
sont plutôt de la majorité c'est les
absents c'est la majorité parce que
figuru qu'il y a quelques députés de
renaissance qui eux étaient favorables
d'ailleurs Figaro se fait un plaisir de
détailler cette histoire je précise que
normalement ils nous rejoint on croise
les doigts Sylvain Maya oui voilà
Sylvain Mayer qui est donc en photo lui
il s'est fait il avait pas soutenu
officiellement mais Figarol a mis en
photo parce que c'est le premier
vice-président du groupe dont quelqu'un
m'important dans le groupe et qu'il
était plutôt favorable au port de
l'uniforme bon mais là où ça se
complique c'est que donc les députés
Renaissance sont plutôt pour en revanche
le gouvernement alors là pas question au
gouvernement on est très ferme on est
catégorique le Nissan à l'école c'est
non on écoute Premier ministre je ne
veux pas de loi sur ce sujet imposer le
port de l'uniforme à tous les élèves
c'est non je sais pas si vous avez
entendu comme moi là j'ai cru comprendre
que PAP and Guy était contre l'uniforme
à l'école mais en fait c'est pas si
clair il est contre mais en même temps
chacun fait un peu ce qui lui plaît on
écoute en revanche
les établissements ont toute liberté par
une modification de règlement intérieur
pour imposer s'il le souhaite une tenue
scolaire je sens votre impatience à
débattre rassurez-vous je conclus
finalement la seule dans la majorité qui
est très ferme très claire sur la
question de l'uniforme c'est Brigitte
Macron ce matin regardez dans Le
Parisien elle dit ouais moi je suis
plutôt pour le port de l'uniforme à
l'école donc le besoin de respectabilité
du rassemblement national est-elle
aujourd'hui qu'ils en sont à s'aligner
sur les positions de Brigitte Macron
donc il y a un thème de débat là parce
que le RN est devenu de caniche de
Brigitte Macron je sais que c'est pas
votre sujet uniforme ou pas uniforme il
y a des bas je merci beaucoup je vais
vous donner la parole dans un tout petit
instant mais on va quand même prendre la
température dans l'hémicycle ce débat il
est en cours Andrea cottarac vous n'êtes
pas député c'est pour ça qu'on attend
Sylvain Maillard bonsoir Marion Becker
est-ce que vous êtes avec nous depuis la
salle des quatre colonnes Marion vous
avez suivi la discussion qui a commencé
il y a un peu plus d'une heure quel est
l'ambiance et on est on ce soir écoutez
c'est une ambiance assez tendue nous en
sommes à l'examen des amendements cet
article unique de cette proposition de
loi donc du rassemblement national pour
rendre l'uniforme obligatoire à l'école
alors cette proposition de loi elle a
très très peu de chances d'être adopté
évidemment le rassemblement national va
la voter et seul les républicains la
soutiendront la droite mais ils ne sont
que trois sur les bancs de l'hémicycle
ce soir eux ils voient un outil
pédagogique essentiel pour lutter contre
les inégalités sociales mais ce sont
bien les seuls à gauche l'opposition et
forme et ferme on parle d'un uniforme
pour cacher la haine de la différence
qui ne résout pas les les inégalités
sociales pour la nuque le
comprenaissances devrait également voter
contre même si quelques députés sont
favorables à l'uniforme mais il refuse
formellement de voter un texte venant du
rassemblement national à l'image du
député Sylvain Maillard qui votre
raconte mais qui préparait avec d'autres
députés une proposition de loi venant de
son groupe du groupe Renaissance à noter
quand même l'absence remarquée du
ministre de l'éducation nationale
papenda dans l'hémicycle ce soir et puis
l'interview aux Parisiens de Brigitte
Macron s'est invité dans l'hémicycle
notamment dans l'intervention en
discussion générale du député de la nup
Paul Vanier qui s'est étonné de cette
interview le jour même ou cette
proposition de loi du rassemblement
national et étudier dans l'hémicycle et
débattus Marion Becker merci beaucoup
Marion cottarac votre groupe donc le
rassemblement national revient avec
cette proposition de loi qu'est-ce qui
vous permet de penser que c'est une
solution franchement on voit que c'est
pas forcément très concluant là où ça ça
a été expérimenté notamment à Béziers ou
bien à Provins non d'abord l'uniforme
existe déjà dans notre pays puisque je
rappelle que en département comme la
Martinique
à l'uniforme à l'école vous avez
d'autres pays de l'Union européenne
comme nos voisins belges qui ont
l'uniforme les Indiens bref
un nombre de pays conséquents maintenant
on a surtout un état du pays qui est le
suivant c'est que d'abord un deux tiers
des Français sont favorables à
l'uniforme qui n'ont pas uniforme
nationale comme vous l'avez dit mais
uniforme par rétablissement
60% exactement 63% exactement nous avons
vu qu'il y a aujourd'hui 11 millions de
pauvres qu'il y a une inégalité sociale
énorme dans notre pays qui se traduit
dans les cours de récréation par de la
violence par de la moquerie voir par du
harcèlement d'ailleurs le représentant
du gouvernement a commencé par cela en
indiquant qu'un élève
c'est ça avec l'uniforme vous pensez que
c'est possible
les moqueries on va limiter le
harcèlement à l'école et puis
troisièmement
un habit commun permet juste pour
comprendre ça peut limiter de la
violence vous savez ça permet d'avoir un
sentiment commun dans un établissement
ça permet d'être à égalité ça permet
d'éviter visuellement sur la forme une
forme de moquerie une forme de
différence sociale entre les élèves la
classe est un endroit où chaque élève
apprend ou un élève essaye d'avoir une
conscience libre et absolue éclairé sur
le monde et non pas uniquement sur une
moquerie ou sur des différences sociales
vous savez l'école c'est un pilier de la
République l'égalité
c'est un une valeur centrale de la
République française je suis d'abord
très étonné que la gauche n'y soit pas
favorable la gauche a déjà abandonné la
lutte des classes aujourd'hui elle est
favorable à la lutte des marques et puis
il y a une réalité du pays si je peux me
permettre qui est quand même assez
importante au-delà du caractère social
c'est le caractère laïque mais
aujourd'hui propose d'aller dans d'abord
sur cette question du marqueur social
parce que voilà Carole derbib on entend
depuis ce matin voilà au moins la tenue
unique l'uniforme permettrait d'éviter
cette tyrannie des marques on peut en
faire un élément d'égalité voire
d'équité d'abord rappeler quand même que
excepté dans quelques départements
ultramarins l'uniforme n'est pas dans la
tradition de de l'école républicaine
alors est-ce que c'est un moyen mettre
un uniforme serait-il un moyen de lutter
contre les inégalités nous on en est pas
nous chef d'établissement que je
représente on en est pas du tout
persuadé il y a d'autres marqueurs
sociaux on peut mettre les élèves en
uniforme mais il y aura toujours un
cahier un stylo une montre qui sera
d'une des baskets un sac à dos un
téléphone portable il y a plein d'autres
marqueurs plutôt que de nous attacher à
cette question de l'élégance des
apparences est-ce qu'on pourrais pas
plutôt travailler sur les questions de
fond comment est-ce qu'on lui contre les
inégalités sociales et scolaires comment
est-ce qu'on élève nos élèves comment
est-ce qu'on les amène voilà la réussite
scolaire c'est ça c'est ces questions de
fond qu'on doit qu'on doit traiter et
comment est-ce qu'on continue de faire
ce qu'on a toujours fait de la pédagogie
et de l'éducation que ce soit sur les
questions de laïcité mais que ce soit
aussi sur les questions de tenue donc
pour vous c'est une fausse bonne idée
clairement c'est pas la priorité il y a
d'autres marqueurs il y a d'autres
choses vous enseignant c'est le
Saint-Denis professeur
d'histoire-géographie vous avez des
collégiens classes de troisième c'est
l'adolescence la vie quelle place il a
dans une classe quand on a 13 14 ans
aujourd'hui la bille il a son importance
parce qu'effectivement les collégiens se
regardent regardent leurs vêtements
regarde la manière dont ils sont
habillés
mais néanmoins je pense que parce que je
suis à Saint-Denis les élèves le
regardent peut-être moins que dans
certains quartiers
ou dans certains quartiers peut-être
plus bourgeois là on regarde on regarde
ce que tu as de la marque est-ce que
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est est-ce
que ça brille ce que tu as mes élèves
souvent n'ont pas les moyens ni d'avoir
de la marque ni de faire que ça brille
donc on est on est moins je crois encore
je suis pas un expert en habit en habit
des jeunes mais je crois qu'on est moins
soumis à cela en tout cas dans mon
établissement c'est l'impression c'est
l'impression que j'ai bonsoir Sylvain
Maillard très attendu sur ce plateau
député Renaissance député de Paris alors
on essaye de comprendre votre position
parce que si j'ai bien compris dans
l'hémicycle là le principal article sur
l'uniforme a été rejeté c'est ça c'est
pour ça que je suis en retard d'ailleurs
je voulais absolument vous avez voté
contre voilà le principe même de ce
texte porté par le rassemblement
national pour quelle raison est-ce que
c'est une raison principe contre le RN
ou c'est parce que vous êtes hostile à
l'uniforme on ne dit pas le retour
puisqu'en fait jamais eu de difforme on
verra avec Jean Gary en France vous êtes
hostile sur le fond ou sur le parti qui
le porte peut-être une position un peu
plus compliquée que celle là parce que
vous avez moitié trop personnel
d'ailleurs c'est connu je suis plutôt
favorable à l'uniforme ce que l'on ne
veut pas d'ailleurs c'est on a travaillé
dessus avec Jean-Michel Blanquer il y a
quelques années parce que c'est un
marronnier ça revient régulièrement
dans le débat quelle est la situation si
vous voulez que ça fonctionne il faut
que l'ensemble de la communauté
éducative de l'établissement soit
favorable à l'uniforme c'est-à-dire les
enseignants les enfants les parents
d'élèves et la direction de de l'école
donc sinon il y a uneanimité locale dans
un établissement pourquoi ça doit être
un projet pédagogique si ce n'est pas le
cas ça ne marche pas toutes les tout ce
qui a été essayé que ce soit à Béziers
que ce soit à Provins d'autres
établissements on regarde toujours ce
qui se passe dans les DOM-TOM et parfois
et là-bas ça marche plutôt bien ça ne
peut pas marcher chez nous il y a plein
d'exemples d'abord qui finance les les
uniformes est-ce que ça des différences
sociales est-ce qu'on ne voit plus les
différences sociales en réalité on les
voit toujours les accessoires les
chaussures le blouson par dessus la
qualité du pull est-ce qu'il a été
racheté plusieurs fois et indirectement
quand vous réfléchissez pardon d'être un
peu long là-dessus mais si jamais
imaginez-vous un enseignant qu'il n'y
ait pas favorable et au fond dans
l'établissement on l’impôt on l'impose
au niveau national plusieurs élèves
arrivent sans uniforme en décidant nous
sommes contre les uniformes qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on rejette les élèves une
journée d'accord
le sujet que vous avez fini par
considérer cette n'était pas une bonne
idée donc vous vous n'êtes plus pour
l'uniforme ça ce soir c'est pas ça du
tout moi je suis je l'ai dit la seule il
faut que ce soit un projet pédagogique
de chaque établissement et je le dis
dans chaque établissement public on a la
capacité de le faire d'ailleurs c'est ce
que les conclusions qu'on avait établi
avec Jean-Michel Blanquer dans chaque
été on peut le faire on voit qu'on est
trop drôle on
exactement j'ai quand même vous faire
écouter Robert Ménard ce matin parce que
il s'étonne sur France Info d'une
certaine d'un certain constat qu'il fait
regarde
les types ils sont contre parce que
c'est le rassemblement national mais
comment on peut être assez stupide Conan
pour pouvoir choisir de dire non
uniquement et te le disent ah c'est le
rassemblement national qui le propose
donc je peux pas voter pour qu'est-ce
que vous répondez à ça et totalement
faux et je vais vous dire un exemple
très précis il y a quelques semaines
plusieurs de députés vous le savez très
bien vous en avez parlé plusieurs
députés de mon groupe Renaissance sont
venus avec cette idée de pourquoi pas
généraliser l'uniforme qu'est-ce qu'on a
décidé collectivement on a dit et ce
moment-là j'assurais l'intérim du groupe
en disant nous allons créer un groupe de
travail jusqu'en mars ils auditionnent
et ensuite si jamais il y a une sorte
d'unanimité de travail dessus pourquoi
pas partir sur une décision
principe vous pourriez voter une
proposition de loi puis après on revient
au fond mais courriers voter à
Renaissance une proposition de loi du RN
oui ou non
en tout cas sur ce sujet là sur ce sujet
là
est-ce que c'est envisageable c'est une
option politique envisageable ou pas oui
si
vous regardez les textes là pour le
moment tout ce qu'on nous propose c'est
c'est du boogie-boulga très clairement
là
nous ne sommes pas d'accord sur le fait
que ce soit obligatoire ça ne marche pas
alors ça ne marche pas de l'historien on
parle toujours du retour c'est le débat
revient mais en fait l'uniforme ne
revient pas parce que il y a eu la
blouse mais il y a jamais eu l'uniforme
en France alors il y a eu brièvement
sous le Premier Empire Napoléon avait
imposé l'uniforme dans les lycées
impériaux pour les internes ça
concernait que une toute petite partie
de la population Yanis a raison de dire
que le problème se pose peut-être plus
dans les établissements bourgeois ceux
ou des distinctions se font par le par
le vêtement que que dans des endroits un
peu plus un peu pauvres mais sur le fond
moi je suis très intéressé par cette
idée parce que c'est bien ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui on est dans une
société fracturée ou le lien social
c'est totalement distendu et il faut le
recréer sous la Troisième République qui
s'est recréé notamment par l'école c'est
créer par l'école parce que avec
l'enseignement libre laïque gratuite on
a construit quelque chose ça s'est
construit aussi par le service militaire
etc et donc le l'école c'est un c'est un
lieu précisément ou peut se refaire se
retisser ce lien social se vivre
ensemble et c'est vrai que donner une
forme d'égalité par le vêtement ça n'est
pas l'alpha et l'oméga c'est une des
contributions à ce qui peut faire ce
lien
j'y suis j'y suis personnellement
favorable à condition et c'est ce qui
était Soulié par cette vie un malheur
Maya et aussi d'ailleurs par par le
ministre on a on avait un moment penser
qu'il était totalement hostile non c'est
la
forme au niveau d'éducation je suis
contre parce qu'effectivement il faut
que soit associé les enseignants les
chefs d'établissement les parents il
faut qu'il y ait un une convergence pour
que ça pour que ça fonctionne mais au
cas où il y a cette convergence moi je
pense que c'est quelque chose d'utile on
a porté aussi la blouse pour des raisons
très très pratique la blouse c'était
simplement pour protéger les les habits
et puis on a pu l'enlever c'est pas du
tout les mêmes enjeux oui mais quelque
part il y avait dans le port de la
blouse aussi une une idée d'égalité une
idée de de se ressembler et cette idée
de se ressembler c'est quelque chose de
fondamental à l'époque soit Troisième
République il fallait
un quelqu'un de Lille n'avait aucun
rapport à ne parlait pas la même langue
n'avez pas la même culture que quelqu'un
de Marseille par exemple et on l'a on
s'est unifié comme ça à travers l'école
et à travers le service militaire alors
vous l'avez dit la plupart des des
élèves dans le monde portent une tenue
uniforme au Royaume-Uni mais aussi en
Asie et en Amérique du Sud en Afrique on
est allé poser des questions à quelques
écoliers français qu'en pensent-ils de
ce possible retour de l'uniforme tour
d'horizon avec Marion Becca
porter ou non l'uniforme les premiers
concernés sont assez partagés bah moi je
pense que c'est bien surtout si c'est
comme comme avant il y a très longtemps
ou il y avait les chaussettes au télé
mocassins avec les jupes c'était très
joli je trouve c'est un peu liberticide
vu que tout le monde a le droit de
s'habiller comme il veut pour pense que
ça permettrait de voir moins les
égalités même si on peut les voir
ailleurs mais compte parce que je pense
ça pourrait faire un peu trop strict
la blouse un lointain souvenir pour la
plupart des écoliers français elle
n'était pas obligatoire mais les enfants
la portaient tous pour une raison très
terre à terre ne pas se tâcher une
habitude abandonnée depuis 1968
sauf dans certaines écoles privées et
dans les outre-mer où le port de la
tenue scolaire voire de l'uniforme est
ancrée comme ici à la Réunion ou encore
en Nouvelle-Calédonie en Martinique en
Guadeloupe et en Guyane un tiers des
écoles on choisit de conserver
l'uniforme l'un des objectifs gommer les
inégalités
dans le monde la majorité des écoliers
porte un uniforme et quand on parle
l'uniforme à l'école on pense forcément
au Royaume-Uni ici c'est une tradition
de plus de 400 ans l'uniforme marque son
appartenance à une école spécifique à
chaque établissement ils sont vus comme
un facteur de cohésion
l'uniforme est donc obligatoire dans les
pays de tradition anglo-saxonnes mais
pas seulement il est aussi obligatoire
en Chine au Japon au Cambodge en
Malaisie ou encore en Thaïlande et au
Vietnam il est présent dans certains
pays d'Afrique il est obligatoire au
Mexique et dans la majorité des pays
d'Amérique latine
on en parle avec Jean garrigue l'idée ce
serait quoi ce serait qu'un
établissement puisque le faire pourquoi
vous défendez la nationalisation si
aujourd'hui on peut déjà le faire au
niveau local les outre-mer devrait être
l'exemple aujourd'hui pour la métropole
puisque ça marche là-bas l'objectif pour
nous c'est ce qui a été dit un petit peu
fausse c'est-à-dire que l'objectif pour
nous c'est de le rendre obligatoire mais
de laisser une parfaite liberté à chaque
établissement d'avoir son propre
uniforme alors on a une hypocrite en
disant les chaussures
sont les mêmes elles sont identiques
dans les autres pays aussi donc ce sont
des fautes moi je crois qu'on a
aujourd'hui une classe politique qui est
assez hypocrite on dit non mais il faut
que la communauté éducative soit
d'accord mais on a ici un débat qui est
censé être sacré c'est à dire que c'est
ce sont les représentants de toute la
nation qui aurait pris acte du de
l'uniforme dans les écoles ensuite on a
le décret d'application ensuite on a
certains nombre de choses qui rendent
crédible la mesure comme dans chaque loi
deuxièmement on a le sentiment
d'appartenance vous voulez créer
national à un pays où on voit dans
certains pays c'est la fierté aussi
d'être dans un établissement avec un
écusson celui de l'école c'est pas
pareil nous avons deux objectifs c'est
d'abord un effacer visuellement les
inégalités sociales qui sont absolument
exacerbées dans notre pays et point
numéro 2 c'est réglé certains problèmes
concrets pardon mais il y a la
communauté éducative il y a aussi la
communauté du renseignement notamment du
renseignement antérieur la DCRI donc pas
le rassemblement national les
renseignements intérieurs sont autorités
de Bovo nous explique dans notre pays on
a eu notamment à la rentrée une
offensive je cite salafo frériste
d'organisation islamistes qui veulent
imposer la Baya ou le camis dans nos
établissements
Jean-Luc Mélenchon disait à ce propos
nos élèves n'ont pas à être déguisés
comme des Pakistanais pourquoi est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui la nupesse nous fait du
gloubi-bouba pour refuser cette mesure
alors qu'ils y étaient favorables
notamment monsieur Corbière deuxièmement
depuis le premier trimestre le premier
trimestre c'est 1400 signalements à la
laïcité dans nos établissements alors
maintenant la classe politique de
prendre acte on va regarder dans le
détail des chiffres vous nous amenez sur
la question de laïcité Yanis roder vous
connaissez très bien ces sujets vous
êtes membre du conseil des sages de la
laïcité on va voir cette image de
l'abeille à tout le monde ne sait pas ce
que c'est que qu'un abaya c'est une
tenue alors on est entre la tenue
culturelle traditionnelle religieuse là
on a pris une photo sur Tik Tok parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de vidéos qui vous
expliquent comment contourner la loi de
2004 sur l'interdiction des signes
religieux d'abord qu'est-ce que vous
voyez il y a les signalements qui vous
remontent qu'est-ce qu'il se passe dans
les établissements dans certains
établissements alors depuis le mois de
janvier février de l'année dernière donc
il y a un an on a vu apparaître dans les
signalements de l'éducation nationale
une montée et une montée importante des
signalements liés au port de signe à
Bahia ou autre ça a commencé en février
à peu près l'année dernière et
effectivement il y a eu une accélération
au deuxième trimestre de l'année 2022
qu'on a retrouvé à la rentrée scolaire
et ce qui a été très intéressant c'est
que dans ce qui nous remontait nous
pouvions observer que les éléments de
langage que l'on trouve se trouve à
Lille Toulouse ou Grenoble était les
mêmes tenues par les jeunes filles c'est
à dire c'est un vêtement ce n'est pas
cultuel c'est culturel je l'ai acheté
chez H&M donc ce n'est pas religieux
voilà par exemple donc on retrouvait ce
type de ce type d'éléments de langage
absolument partout ce qui signifie est
le L'Express avait fait un papier en
septembre je crois ou octobre je ne sais
plus sur justement une note du cipdr le
comité intermédiaire de la prévention à
la lutte contre la radicalisation qui
montrait qu'il avait une offensive sur
les réseaux sociaux donc d'officine
islamiste
identitarisme islamiste et qui qui
proposait justement ces éléments de
langage et qui étaient repris juste un
exemple ce type de d'abaya que vous avez
montré sur sur le réseau de Tik Tok j'ai
eu vent par exemple au mois d'octobre
d'un événement comme ça dans un lycée
breton en quelques 30 minutes la jeune
fille avait 417000 vues donc il y a un
sujet réseau sociaux aussi c'est alors
voilà les chiffres 313 signalements pour
atteinte à la laïcité en septembre 2022
dans les établissements publics 720 en
octobre 2022 et un ministre de
l'éducation nationale Papé Ndiaye qui
parle de vagues de tenue pouvant être
considérés comme religieuse si le
Maillard au fond se débat sur l'uniforme
est-ce que c'est pas ça l'objectif
trouver les moyens
d'empêcher que on contourne la loi de
2004 en s'habillant tous pareils c'est
pas ça que vous recherchez dans la
majorité de façon voilà plus précise
moi j'ai entendu beaucoup de choses
beaucoup et j'ai beaucoup travaillé et
dans le passé sur l'uniforme on peut y
voir plein de choses positifs sur
l'égalité sociale on voit que ça peut
être contourne et sur le fait de faire
en sorte qu'il y ait pas de vêtements
islamistes
identitaires comme vous la dit Yanis
Ruder on peut voir plein de choses
dessus ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
qu'il faut qu'il y ait une acceptabilité
dans chaque établissement je le redis on
n'est pas hostile moi je ne suis à titre
personnel je l'ai toujours dit plutôt
favorable mais il faut absolument que la
communauté éducative parce qu'avant tous
nos enfants ils viennent à l'école pour
apprendre et pour apprendre il faut
qu'il y ait une communauté éducative qui
porte le même projet si si on imaginez
vous si dans chaque école ça devient au
fond on impose quelque chose aussi fort
mais et que c'est rejeté par la
communauté éducative on est en train de
créer un problème supplémentaire sans
être sûr de résoudre les problèmes dont
on vient de parler donc moi je le redis
regardons c'est possible à l'heure
actuelle de le faire dans certains
établissements peut-être que nous dans
notre travaux au mois de mars on
proposera plus tard pourquoi pas une
expérimentation une aide pour les
établissements qui souhaitent le faire
on regardera si ça marche mais avant
tout ce qui est important c'est que la
communauté éducative par an enfant
professeur soit accepte souhaitent porte
ce projet sinon
favorables alors 63% attendez c'est un
sondage ça dépend de la question pour
l'instant la loi n'est pas votée
les chefs d'établissement que vous
représentez dans votre syndicat comment
font-ils très concrètement sur le
terrain je ne sais pas si vous vous êtes
directement voilà confronté à ces sujets
mais il y en a d'autres notamment dans
la liberté populaire comment on fait
quand on a l'armature législative mais
on contourne très concrètement la loi au
quotidien quelles sont les éléments
voilà qui vous permettent de trouver des
réponses est-ce que vous êtes accompagné
la loi de 2004 est clair quand un élève
ou une élève vient avec une tenue
religieuse on entame un dialogue avec
l'élève et avec sa famille et on lui
demande d'enlever la tenue maintenant si
les lèvres refusent et bien on prend on
prend des mesures comme une atteinte à
la loi 2004 pour vous oui c'est une
c'est une tenue religieuse c'est une
considération le problème c'est que ça
n'allait pas une au niveau de la loi
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait concrètement
si l'uniforme je comprends des nous
détournent des des vrais sujets
qu'est-ce qu'on fait
il me semble évident que alors d'abord
la Baya
est utilisé en réalité dans la plupart
des cas dans un but religieux il faut
pas se voiler la face mais là où cela
devient plus compliqué c'est que la Baya
en réalité n'est pas un vêtement
religieux ça un vêtement culturel d'une
partie d'une partie du monde
c'est-à-dire du Moyen-Orient et qui peut
être porté par des musulmans ou comme
par des chrétiennes au Moyen-Orient et
c'est le cas donc mais il faut pas se
leurrer les jeunes filles en France qui
le portent le porte d'abord vraiment
pour des questions religieuses c'est à
dire pour une question
identitaire communautaire mais aussi
pour masquer les formes puisque selon un
islam rigoriste les femmes ne doivent
pas montrer leur forme la difficulté
pour les chefs d'établissement c'est de
faire ressortir l'intention puisque si
ces jeunes filles ont ces éléments de
langage c'est pas culturel c'est
culturel je le porte parce que c'est
joli acheter chez ACM etc toute la
difficulté pour les chefs
d'établissement qui se retrouvent en
première ligne c'est bien sûr de faire
ressortir l'intention qu'il y a derrière
et on sait très bien que beaucoup de
jeunes filles parce qu'elles sont
cornaquées on va dire par les réseaux
sociaux par ces officines sur les
réseaux sociaux vont tenir les éléments
de langage qui vont mettre en difficulté
les chefs d'établissement face à cela
alors pour professeur que vous êtes
l'uniforme serait une solution ou pas
non je ne dis pas une solution vous
savez puisque vous me posez la question
je suis voilà je suis un moyen oui je
suis dubitatif mais vous savez je
poserai la question autrement
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
situation où une partie de la jeunesse
ne se retrouve plus sur nos bases on va
dire sur nos bases républicaine ne
comprend plus très bien ce qu'est la
laïcité on y adhère pas
et perd aussi le sens de l'intérêt
général vous savez symboliquement ce
lieu fictif de l'école
vivait pas fictif mais je veux dire
de ce lieu de l'école peut-être une
aussi un lieu d'éducation à la
communauté politique voilà qu'est-ce que
c'est que la communauté politique
qu'est-ce que c'est le sens de l'intérêt
général et effectivement un uniforme
qu'on appellerait pas comme ça je veux
dire une blouse comme vous voulez parce
que uniforme ça fait très militaire
quand même et du coup tout de suite oh
là là c'est pas beau c'est pas bien mais
tenue commune et bien voilà
symboliquement fictivement on est dans
la dans une sorte de construction
citoyenne bon on peut peut-être comme le
disait monsieur Mayer il réfléchir voilà
André pour terminer ce débat il y a une
étude édifiante aujourd'hui qui est
sortie à la Fondation Jean Jaurès avec
l'Ifop qui montre que l'obscurantisme
gagne du terrain chez les jeunes
notamment par exemple sur la question de
la théorie de l'évolution un jeune sur
quatre doutes de cette théorie un jeune
français sur 6 trouve que un doute que
la terre soit ronde et pense que la
terre est plate est-ce que au fond c'est
pas ça le vrai sujet est-ce que au fond
uniforme ne détourne pas des vraies
urgences lutter contre ça lutter contre
les vrais inégalités comme l'orthographe
ça aussi c'est un marqueur social je
crois qu'en réalité c'est le même c'est
le même problème quand vous voyez
qu'aujourd'hui les obscures antistes les
radicaux mènent une offensive c'est pas
moi qui le dit encore une fois ce sont
les services de renseignements et que
les conséquences sont que un enseignant
sur deux refuses de parler de laïcité à
ces élèves mais bien évidemment que les
jeunes générations refuseront d'en
parler
mais je poursuis simplement on a cessé
le même problème alors on peut parler
des problèmes de forme il faut soutenir
nos professeurs et aussi les problèmes
de fonds lorsque on propose
effectivement que les enseignants soient
mieux payés ils étaient embauchés à 2,3
fois le SMIC dans les en 1984
aujourd'hui c'est 1,1 fois le SMIC quand
on le fait c'est même personne refuse de
voter quand on souhaite imposer la
laïcité la liberté d'expression
l'égalité la fraternité à travers cette
tenue commune des uniformes tout le
monde votre compte donc à un moment
donné
aujourd'hui vous avez la possibilité
quelque chose non rien du tout Sylvain
Maya
que je viens d'entendre à un enseignant
comment sa carrière d'ailleurs on l'a
fait on a fait échanger 2023 comment ça
carrière 2000 euros c'est pas 1,1 le
SMIC je sais pas combien le SMIC
est rejeté c'est un sujet qui reviendra
dessus je redis les établissements qui
souhaitent s'en saisir si la communauté
éducative le souhaite ça peut être un
projet d'établissement pour nous ça ne
peut être comme ça que ça fonctionne
typiquement sinon ça ne marchera pas
allez on va s'arrêter là merci à tous
merci d'être venu débattre sur le
plateau de LCP vous restez avec moi Jean
garrigue dans une dizaine de minutes
vous les voyez les parties prises de nos
affranchis tous sur les retraites ce
soir pour Henri et Pierre-Henri Tavoy le
débat vous allez le voir manque de
philosophie Fanny chaîne nous dira
pourquoi le front syndical est uni mais
surtout si cette unité est durable et
puis elle demande un gamin dans Bourbon
Express le 8 mai de François Bayrou et
Edouard Philippe à cette réforme des
retraites mais on va parler avec vous
maintenant Jean Gary de votre livre et
on va plonger dans les archives de la 5e
République et lisait contre Matignon
c'est votre dernier opus je le disais ce
duo pour le moins inattendu le super
jupitérien et sa superintendante c'est
comme ça que vous les voyez
incontestablement depuis précisément on
a vu Nicolas Sarkozy et François Fillon
qui est tous les deux au départ avait
théorisé le Premier ministre
collaborateur
incontestablement quelqu'un comme
Elisabeth borne comme Jean Castex
d'ailleurs se situe plutôt dans cette
héritage là qui est lié à la
surpriseidentialisation du système ou le
Premier ministre n'est pas véritablement
le celui ou celle qui dirige le
gouvernement et l'exécutant de la
volonté président en l'espèce
manifestement elle n'était pas son
premier choix elle n'était pas son
premier choix alors
nonobstant ces qualités qui sont réelles
et la manière dont je trouve elle s'est
imposée alors que il y avait quand même
beaucoup de critiques beaucoup de
réticences au départ elle s'est imposée
comme quelqu'un qui est capable aussi de
jouer de jouer son rôle de d'entraîner
un gouvernement de jouer un rôle de
négociation sociale ce qu'elle sait très
bien faire ou même politique en revanche
c'est très clair que dans la macronie
dans le système macronien il y a un
président qui est jupiterien et qui
décide de tout et on voit bien y compris
sur la réforme des retraites très
récemment dans son discours aux Français
du 31 décembre c'est lui qui a donné le
cadre de ce qui était la réforme si vous
comparez avec ce qui s'était passé en
1995 pour une réforme similaire en tout
cas quelque chose qui a les braquer
beaucoup de Français c'est Alain Juppé
qui a un carnet totalement la réforme à
lui alors justement il y a la lettre il
y a l'esprit de la Constitution ces
rédacteurs avaient très clairement et
Michel Debré en tête créer un partage un
périmètre avec des rôles très clairs le
président au dessus de la mêlée garant
de l'unité de la nation le Premier
ministre qui gouverne qui gouverne et
est-ce que ce partage là a été respecté
une fois dans l'histoire ou très vite le
président a grignoter du pouvoir très
vite le président à grignoté du pouvoir
le général de Gaulle le premier en
réalité c'est vrai que de Gaulle avait
son domaine réservé là les affaires
étrangères la défense il gouvernait avec
des ministres qui lui mettaient fidèles
permet ce merle à côté Maurice de
Murville et laissait a priori les
affaires intérieures à adorer mais en
réalité dès que ça devenait chaud dès
que ça devenait important c'est le
président qui qui prenait la main
prenons quelques exemples on va les
regarder sur cet écran de Gaulle
Pompidou c'est plutôt l'entente parfaite
du moins au début du mois au début parce
que Pompidou avait été son directeur de
cabinet donc au fond pour de Gaulle
c'était assez naturel que en tant que
Premier ministre il soit une de super
directeurs de cabinet mais il l'a laissé
faire il allait vraiment laissé faire et
tout le projet de relance économique le
projet industriel de Pompidou c'était
vraiment Georges Pompidou jusque
jusqu'au moment de crise jusqu'au moment
de rupture qui a été la crise de Mai 68
parce que là en mai 68 de Gaulle a été
complètement dépassé par les événements
Pompidou a pris des choses en main
l'entourage de Georges Pompidou certains
voulaient même que voilà que on fasse
partir le général de Gaulle et là ça
c'est ça s'est cassé parce que dès que
le premier mise prend un petit peu trop
d'importance mort un peu sur le
périmètre du président de la République
ça peut plus fonctionner Mitterrand
Maurois c'est intéressant parce que là
c'est l'histoire d'un couple parfait au
départ chacun est dans son rôle chacun
se respecte mon roi admir Mitterrand
tout le monde le sait et puis tout va
dérailler oui alors et Mitterrand avait
une grande affection pour pour Pierre
Mauroy mais tout a déraillé finalement
assez vite
ça c'est moins sûr parce que dès
198283 il y avait le projet
éventuellement de remplacer mon roi par
Jacques Delors ou par d'autres bon mais
sa véritablement explosé en 1994 sur la
question de l'école enfin du service
unique de l'enseignement public qui
était prévu par par les socialistes que
Mauroy a soutenu ou plutôt il a soutenu
son ministre de l'éducation nationale
qui était Alain Savary que détestait
Mitterrand et mitterrances à sacrifié et
à utiliser Mauroy comme fusible comme ça
s'est fait beaucoup sous la Cinquième
République l'hyper présidentialisation
ça c'est Nicolas Sarkozy qui l'a inventé
qu'il a porté à son paroxysme oui ça
c'est une certitude l'hyper Président
c'est la manière d'intervenir
directement depuis l'Élysée sur tous les
problèmes qui se posaient de réagir
comme ça à tout bout de champ ce qui
fait que des facto vous vous empiétez
sur le domaine du Premier ministre ce
qu'il avait plus ou moins autorisé en
l'appelant son collaborateur ce que
Fillon lui-même avant d'arriver à
Matignon avait lui-même reconnu et puis
ce qui est intéressant c'est que à
l'épreuve des faits François Fillon a
voulu reconquérir son territoire et ça a
donné des des scènes de ménage
perpétuels entre les deux hommes que je
raconte dans le livre parce que
c'est pas si simple que ça de rester un
premier ministre aux ordres du président
et puis elle est rivaux alors là on
aurait pu prendre plein de couples on
pourrait prendre du terreau regard on a
choisi Hollande Valls pour rester proche
de nous rivaux ou pas rivaux c'est
compliqué parce que au début ils sont
très quand même très main dans la main
pour essayer de redresser ce qui s'est
passé pendant les deux années où
Jean-Marc Ayraud était à Matignon où ça
s'est pas très bien ça a pas très bien
fonctionné c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire et va le servir comme un super
communicant quelqu'un qui a une très
bonne popularité et qui va aider
François Hollande à retrouver justement
cette popularité perdue et puis et puis
il y a un troisième larron et c'est ça
surtout qui va mettre de le feu dans ce
dans ce couple qui fonctionnait
finalement pas si mal au départ
troisième lance c'est c'est Emmanuel
Macron et Emmanuel Macron qui prend de
plus en plus de d'importance en tant que
ministre et je me souviens qu'avec
Emmanuel Valls quand même la principale
question des journalistes c'était est-ce
que vous êtes est-ce que vous serez
loyal alors c'est déjà qu'il y a un loup
non oui parce que il y a toujours un
loup quand vous avez un Premier ministre
qui a la perspective la possibilité à un
moment ou un autre de devenir président
de la République il y a forcément un
moment quelque chose qui va se tendre
entre entre les deux hommes alors
quelquefois ça s'est tendu après c'était
le cas pour pour Pompidou et de Gaulle
ils ont quand même tenu presque jusqu'au
bout mais mais en général quand vous
avez un Premier ministre qui a une
ambition regardez ce qui s'est passé
avec Édouard Philippe tout le montre que
la théorie du fusible du parano
paratonnerre est complètement
terminée et on en est on en est vraiment
sorti puisque le président décide de
tout tout procède de l'eau d'huile
est-ce que ça peut durer longtemps comme
ça à l'heure de la réforme des
institutions est-ce que il faut pas
mettre fin à l'hypocrisie on supprime le
Premier ministre et en rendant
responsable président devant moi
exactement pour l'inverse en fait moi je
pense qu'au contraire il faut revenir à
l'esprit initial de la Cinquième
République pourquoi parce que si vous
enlevez au président de la République le
pouvoir d'être un super Premier ministre
et un chef de majorité parlementaire
qu'il est parce que objectivement les
élections législatives arrivent juste
après la présidentielle et font du
président un chef de majorité
parlementaire qui n'est plus le
président de tous les Français il le
chef de 35% des Français donc si vous
redonnez au Premier ministre cette
fonction qui est la sienne de diriger le
gouvernement et de diriger la majorité
vous permettez au président de
s'abstraire de s'exclure de ce j'allais
dire du marigot politique
avant les présidentielles comme c'était
le cas mais en tout cas déconnecter les
deux élections et refaire je le répète
du Premier ministre un véritable chef de
gouvernement ça s'appelle Elisée contre
Matignon de 1958 à nos jours chez
Taillandier le couple infernal on plonge
dans la 5e République avec plaisir et
comme promis on va passer à nos
affranchis ce soir Fanny guinochet Elsa
mondingava et Pierre-Henri prévoyau on
vous accueille tout de suite
et merci d'être là dans ce nouveau
studio pour ça vous regarde Fanny
guinochet France Info Pierre-Henri
tavoyau philosophe président du collège
de philosophie on va parler retraite
avec vos angles respectifs dans un
instant mais on commence avec le bourbon
Express l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
nous est racontée cette semaine par Elsa
mondingava tous les soirs une histoire
d'amis pas forcément oui bah je vais
vous raconter l'histoire de trois amis
allez vous l'avez dit le mot et
peut-être un peu fort on va parler trois
alliés trois composantes de la majorité
présidentielle je vous le rappelle
autour du président Emmanuel Macron il y
a deux partenaires François Bayrou le
président du MoDem est l'ancien Premier
ministre Édouard Philippe président
aujourd'hui d'horizon à l'Assemblée
nationale ici ça se décline en trois
groupes politiques Aurore berger
Jean-Paul Mattei pour le modem et
Laurent Marc angélique pour horizon
alors justement tout ce beau monde et
bien il était réuni hier matin au
lendemain de la présentation de la
réforme des retraites réunion autour de
la première ministre Elisabeth borne
c'est un message un peu incontournable
vous le savez le gouvernement a beaucoup
traité la droite la question de laisser
penser que Elisabeth borne oublie son
propre camp elle a voulu donc remercier
les parlementaires de la majorité
écoutez
ce texte vous doit beaucoup ça fait des
mois que nous en parlons régulièrement
que nous en parlons évidemment à chacun
des petits déjeuners de la majorité donc
on l'a construit ensemble en lien avec
les trois groupes moi j'ai 116 échangé
avec François Bayrou avec Edouard
Philippe avec Stéphane séjourné et donc
c'est vraiment notre projet commun voilà
Stéphane c'est j'en ai patron de
renaissance alors vous l'avez compris
hier matin Myriam leur est à la
mobilisation en rang serré prêt pour la
bataille et ça au cas où on l'avait pas
compris bien on nous l'a répété à
plusieurs reprises lors d'une conférence
de presse
vous l'avez vu on est mobilisé et soudé
sur cette réforme qui est une bonne
réforme on veut l'accompagner nous
allons être à fond derrière le
gouvernement je n'ai aucun doute
évidemment sur la solidité du pack que
vous avez devant vous voilà ça va mieux
on le disant n'empêche que c'est pas si
évident à l'unité entre ces trois ces
trois composantes de la majorité alors
on va nous dire qu'on cherche toujours
mais je sais pas comment sont vos amis à
vous mais moi les miens généralement ils
sont un peu plus enthousiastes quand je
vais je m'apprête à vivre un moment
difficile là le soutien c'était du bout
des lèvres regardez François Bayrou au
lendemain de la conférence de presse
elle est améliorable cette réforme des
retraites on a connu quand même plus
chaleureux comme soutien et doit Édouard
Philippe dans le point lui dit si la
mesure que le gouvernement propose a le
même effet sur l'équilibre qui en report
à 65 ans très bien alors j'en rajoute
peut-être un peu sur la nonchalance mais
en tout cas bon c'est pas non plus le
franc soutien et puis quelques lignes
plus tard il accuse le gouvernement
d'acheter la paix sociale avec des
chèques
on entendra le l'ancien Premier ministre
alors qu'est-ce qu'il cherche Édouard
Philippe François Bayrou c'est déjà 2027
qui les obsède oui évidemment et ça ça a
le don d'agacer certains députés
Renaissance regardez cette confidence
que me faisait en off un député ce n'est
pas responsable de leur part de venir
brouiller le message global pour
promouvoir leurs intérêts politiques
évidemment on le sait manuel Macron il
ne sera pas candidat il ne peut pas
l'être un troisième mandat la garde de
succès bien elle a déjà commencé Elsa
forcément pour l'historien de la 5ème
que vous êtes vous vous dites l'histoire
se répète oui mais on voit on voit à
quel point là encore en mesure à quel
point j'allais dire les difficultés d'un
Premier ministre qui essaie de faire une
coalition politique et vous voyez bien
que tout ça se heurte à quoi à
l'explosion de de la macronie et à des
ambitions présidentielles c'est ça c'est
ça qui demande de plus en plus on a
l'impression j'ajouterai que j'ajouterai
que c'est quand même Édouard Philippe
qui avait fait échouer le projet initial
qui à mon sens
un projet voilà réforme par point la
réforme par point qu'il voulait à
laquelle il voulait substituer ceux qui
va se faire c'est une réforme
paramétrique donc on voit très bien et
on voit bien aussi que François Bayrou
est sur une très très différente de
celle de de en tout cas de d'élisabetho
le mercredi vous pensez qu'il survivra à
Macron ou c'est déjà en cours de
déliquescence comme tous les comme tous
les les mouvements qui reposent sur
l'incarnation d'un homme sur Madame
providentiel il va il va exploser à
terme est-ce qu'il réussira à se
rénover ou à ce ce réinventer comme
l'avait réussi le gaullisme en
s'incarnant dans des personnalités je ne
le pense pas parce qu'on a aujourd'hui
oui moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
passage la société française au
contraire elle a besoin de de faire
renaître les vieux partis qui ont été
dissous en 2017 que c'est c'est ça qui
correspond beaucoup plus à cette idée à
cette à cet équilibre que les Français
en 2022
des vieux parties non plus à faire à
suivre il manquerait de philosophie ce
débat Pierre-Henri je vais un peu
plaiséité on parle de d'équilibre des
caisses en tout ça est très important
bien sûr mais il y a au cœur du problème
c'est vrai il y a une question
existentielle qu'il faut éclairer avec
des données démographiques je rappelle
quelques données en 1900 l'espérance de
vie et de 40 ans aujourd'hui elle est
près de 80 ça veut dire qu'on vit une
existence de plus que nos ancêtres
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait question
existentielle ensuite ce gain
d'espérance de vie en général on dit
qu'on le gagne à la fin mais c'est pas
tout à fait vrai on le gagne au milieu
avec une jeunesse qui s'allonge et à la
fin également avec une vieillesse qui se
pluralise avec l'âge des seniors
fringants avec les âgés vaillants avec
la sénile dépendant enfin voilà il y a
plusieurs vieillesse et puis
troisièmement effectivement on vit plus
longtemps on vieillit plus longtemps
mais en effet avec le monde économique
La Sept vieillesse est un peu mise au
rebut parce qu'on est dans une logique
de l'innovation donc on vieillit plus
longtemps mais en même temps on est
obsolète plutôt donc si je vous
comprends bien c'est donner
existentielles dont vous nous parlez
sont pas assez prises en compte pas
assez expliqué c'est trop technique trop
techno cette présentation aussi parce
qu'il y a une sorte de changement
profonde du sens de la retraite elle a
été conçue originellement pour être un
court temps de repos après un long temps
de labeur d'ailleurs un cours un temps
de repos très très court bismar qu'il a
inventé on lui reprochait d'avoir
inventé la retraite pour les morts
c'est-à-dire faire en sorte que les
ouvriers n'atteignent jamais cet âge
aujourd'hui c'est devenu quelque chose
de tout à fait différent c'est un
longtemps
d'épanouissement après une longue une
vie de labeur en vérité de plus en plus
courte en fait le travail sur le plan du
temps
occupe même si il nous prend beaucoup la
tête
occupe très peu de temps objectivement
donc il y a une sorte de retour à
l'idéalisation de la retraite telle
qu'elle était c'était le cas dans la
philosophie antique c'est là où je peux
mettre de la philosophie il y a deux
modèles de retraite il y a le modèle 6
seronien dans son traité sur la
vieillesse parle de la retraite en
disant le vieux est sage il est
énergique il est performant c'est un peu
le gentleman farmer qui parce qu'il est
débarrassé des pulsions qu'il empêche de
vivre et donc il fait plus et mieux que
le jeûne face à ce premier modèle il y a
le modèle augustinien alors lui c'est la
retraite monastique c'est l'idée que il
faut quitter les vanités du monde pour
se consacrer à la seule chose qui est
importante le travail pour son salut et
donc on a en quelque sorte l'idéal c'est
quoi alors contemporain c'est la
synthèse des deux modèles c'est la
motion de synthèse si je puis dire la
motion de synthèse en effet de ces deux
modèles avec deux deux éléments à la
fois d'un côté l'idéalisation de la
retraite et puis corrélativement la
dévalorisation du travail ça c'est un
point aussi assez intéressant parce que
ces deux mondes antiques dans le monde
entier qu'on n'aime pas beaucoup le
travail c'est pour les esclaves ou pour
les gens qui ne s'occupent pas de leur
salut et donc là il y a la
dévalorisation du travail et c'est deux
points effectivement pose problème parce
qu'on est dans une situation où
dévaloriser le travail dans le monde
contemporain c'est pas forcément très
très positif du coup ces deux points
doivent être disons pondéré avec l'idée
qu'il faut effectivement peut-être
sortir du triptyque on avait en tête et
qui est problématique pour l'existence
c'est à dire formation travail retraite
on se forme pour travailler on travaille
pour être à la retraite mais on est
retraite pourquoi faire donner du sens
de la deuxième élément enfin la retraite
c'est pas qu'un droit social il faut
aussi rappeler que dans les existences
contemporaines c'est une véritable
cassure cassure au personnage on perd
ses amis on perd ses relations on perd
son rythme de vie et d'une certaine
façon on se focalisant sur le droit à la
retraite on oublie que la retraite peut
être un problème et ça ça peut être
aussi très très mal vécu la question de
l'âge est capital pour le financement
mais je pense aussi que la question la
transition travail retraite est
essentielle pour l'existence
individuelle c'est là il faut mettre un
peu de philo
vous êtes d'accord il faut penser la
retraite véritablement
tristes à la retraite non mais c'est on
voit bien aussi y compris pour dans les
choix de civilisation qui sont les
nôtres déjà Michel Rocard à l'époque
parler de l'utilisation du loisirs etc
donc c'est il faut penser aussi en
termes philosophique enfin en terme ou
au moins en terme culturelle il faut
penser à condition que le pays ne soit
pas bloqué Fanny c'est sûr on va parler
on va parler du climat social on entend
tout et ce contraire ça va exploser les
syndicats sont unis depuis 12 ans c'est
une grande première historique et en
même temps on nous dit peut-être que
c'est pas si évident à quoi faut-il
s'attendre vous qui les côtoyer c'est
toujours un peu difficile mais par
exemple aujourd'hui il y a quand même eu
une annonce qui n'a pas dû être une très
bonne nouvelle pour la première ministre
c'est celle de la CGT
raffinerie pétrole la branche pétrole
qui a quand même déposé un préavis de
grève parce que pour eux la retraite
c'est avant tout un acquis dont ils
entendent bien profiter et donc ils
annoncent déjà des débrayages dès le
mois de janvier le 19 le 26 et le 6
février le 6 février c'est le 1er jour
des départs en vacances en tout cas
c'est au moment des vacances d'hiver et
évidemment les raffineries on pense tout
de suite à la menace de pénurie de
carburant c'est pas très vieux ça date
de l'automne et c'est ce type de
contestation justement que redoute le
plus le gouvernement c'est-à-dire des
blocages extrêmement ciblés dans des
endroits stratégiques l'énergie les
transports qui débordent les mots
d'ordre des grandes centrales voilà
beaucoup plus que des grands cortèges
avec beaucoup de gens dans la rue et
d'ailleurs dans les transports là aussi
attendez-vous le 19 jeudi prochain à une
grève puissante demande en tout cas
appelle la RATP par exemple le risque
c'est quoi le retour aussi de mouvement
comme les gilets jaunes alors
effectivement ce risque des panneaux de
sachant que les gilets jaunes ils ont
essayé de se relancer plusieurs fois ça
n'a jamais marché mais c'est
effectivement ce type de mouvement un
peu spontané corporatiste qui se donne
rendez-vous sur les réseaux sociaux le
gouvernement l'écran ces mouvements là
parce qu'ils sont très difficiles vous
avez pas de leader c'est difficile de
d'établir un dialogue avec eux mais les
syndicats aussi parce que les syndicats
et bien ils se font doubler et surtout
souvent ils obtiennent bien plus
beaucoup plus vite que les syndicats
eux-mêmes regardaient encore la grève
des contrôleurs de la SNCF ils ont
claqué un mouvement au moment de la
période de Noël ils ont été très très
vite reçus par la direction qui a quand
même lâché quelques primes qui n'était
pas soutenu par tous les syndicats ces
mouvements ils ne concernent pas que les
salariés et non c'est là où il faut être
attentif c'est-à-dire que par exemple en
ce moment une des craintes c'est le
mouvement des petits patrons de cette
France qui se lève tôt les boulangers
qui travaillent et qui n'arrivent pas à
s'en sortir à cause notamment des prix
de l'énergie et d'ailleurs vous avez vu
là le gouvernement y compris Emmanuel
Macron lui-même est monté très très vite
au créneau pour essayer d'éteindre la
grogne ça n'empêche que les boulangers
font ont prévu un mouvement le 23
janvier jour de présentation de ce
projet de réforme des retraites devant
le Conseil des ministres et selon une du
renseignement il y aurait ce risque
d'explosion sociale
ce risque très fort de mouvement
citoyens qui viendrait pris dans une
débordée débordée et ça pour le coup et
bien c'est difficile de prévoir mais une
chose est sûre pour l'instant le mot
d'ordre du gouvernement c'est même pas
peur Jean garrigue le regard de
l'historien à la fois sur ces grands
mouvements sociaux ces grands bras de
fer avec des grandes centrales
puissantes bien plus puissantes qu'elles
ne sont aujourd'hui face à ces petits
mouvements autonomes qui peuvent bloquer
tout un pays la gilet jaunisation du
mouvement social ça me semble être
l'événement majeur de ces quelques de
ces dernières années et on voit bien que
ce cette opposition à la réforme pour
les pour les syndicats c'est presque
l'ultime chance justement de d'échapper
à ce à cette gilet jauneisation de
restaurer un petit peu
la puissance de ces corps intermédiaires
qui sont en perpétuel
déliquescence comme d'ailleurs tout
toutes les instances de régulation de
notre société commerçants les petits
patrons ces boulangers qui sont voilà
des lieux de liens sociaux très
importants très politiques aussi ça fait
penser à quoi c'est pas l'électorat
premier de d'Emmanuel Macron en tout cas
on pourrait retourner à ce qui était le
mouvement poujadiste pas par exemple et
qui est quelque chose
c'est encore différent du modèle les
gilets jaunes c'était différent du
mentons qui lui-même était différent de
on pourrait remonter aussi la Révolution
française et montrer à quel point la
question du pain était décisive mais je
veux dire que le pour moi ce qui se joue
dans ce dans ce conflit là c'est
justement la manière dont les syndicats
vont pouvoir accaparer le mouvement
politique ils font leur première grève
unitaire le 19 parce que
Mélenchon fait une grande marge contre
les reins ça fait déjà un paquet de
dates
dans la rue entre les politiques les
syndicats les boulangers on va s'arrêter
là merci les affranchis à demain Elsa
merci Jean Gary je rappelle le titre de
votre livre Élisée contre Matignon de 58
à nos jours le couple infernal chez
thaïlandais merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis tout de suite votre soirée
documentaire avec Jean-Pierre Gratien à
demain très belle soirée
[Musique]